Sir! it's time for you to stop this unhealthy behavior. No, it's not.
You need to take responsibility for your life. Not right now, I don't.
And it starts by raising your son.
I'm sorry, I literally have no idea what you're talking about!
The young orphan you adopted at the gala, remember.
(Laughing) Wow! stairs. Wheee...
He's been living here for the past week.
Hello tabbblllleee!!! Whooo...
And I must say I've grown rather fond of  the young lad.
Hello! secret camera.
You should get to know him.
You and he have a lot in common.
Doesn't he deserve a chance for someone to take him under their wing.
As I took you under mine.
Alfred, you've been watching way too many lifetime movies and drinking Chardonnay! It's Pinot Grigio, sir! Whatever it is!
You wanna play games, do you batman? Save the city or catch your greatest enemy.
You think you're my greatest enemy? What drives you to warm up then, the way that I do? Superman.
Superman isn't a bad guy. I like to fight around.
You seriously saying that there's nothing special about us. There is no us.
Never will be.
Now, you're gonna defuse that bomb.
(Music)
Batman, we love you! Thanks for saving the city.
You're welcome.
Hey, computer. I'm home.
(Echo)
(Music)
Master Bruce, you need to take responsibility for your life and it starts by raising the young orphan you adopted at...
It's the Batcave!  Can I get a costume? Fine.
I love it. I got an idea. !!!  Ripped. It's better.
I can only look you in the eyes right now!
(Music)
Gotham city is the most crime ridden city in the world.
We need to team up with Batman.
!!! What?!!!!
I'm back. Introducing the worst villains in the history of the universe.
The Riddler. Catwoman.  Penguin. Gentleman Ghost. Calenderman and the Condiment King.
Are you making some of those up? Nope, they are all real.
(Music) You guys ready to save Gotham city?
(Music continues...)
I am so sorry!
As soon as I get back to the Batcave, I will make sure that Alfred to put seatbelts on there.
But, for the time being I'm just gonna put my arm right here.
Hey Batman! I'm rubbing my butt all over your stuff.
You're gonna have to rename this as the Butt-mobile.